south carolina senator lindsey graham
senator thanks for being here uh merry
christmas happy new year always great to
see you
can you name one thing senator you're
right there
uh making donald trump look better every
day
i don't know no not really when you look
at it the problem p the problem pete is
that the left the radical left has biden
in a box he can't make the adjustments
on the border he needs to
to secure the border remain in mexico is
imposed by the courts and he can't
change our bor his border policy because
the left won't let him he can't expand
drilling for oil and natural gas here at
home to become energy independent again
because the left won't let him and when
it comes to foreign policy is not a left
problem he's just incompetent he's been
wrong about everything for 40 years
there's a one-two punch uh brewing here
radical islam is on the rise and raging
in afghanistan and you have an open
southern border if something doesn't
change 2022 could be the most dangerous
year for america since 1939 and the
world at large
i want to get to that we're going to get
to that in a moment because we are in a
very dangerous moment
in the world with a with an absentee
commander-in-chief there's no doubt
about it but when you if you're putting
your finger on the pulse of 22 does this
look as big or bigger than 94 in 2010
not to get ahead of ourselves but the
dissatisfaction is and incompetence is
so high republicans have a golden
opportunity here
right
if we don't blow it uh think of the word
backlash there's a backlash coming
against the most radical domestic policy
agenda in the history of the united
states with a 50-50 senate and a
five-seat majority the democrats have
misplayed their hand they think they
have a mandate they don't have so if the
republicans can remain disciplined
policy is our friend remember the trump
years on the border
isis
afghanistan energy independence we
should talk every day about the
differences between our policies in
terms of domestic
policies and international policies
every day so 1994 i came in with a class
of 94. we had a contract with america
promising people we would do these 10
things if you put us in charge we need
an american a first agenda to run on
they suck as part of the deal but we
need to be for things secure the border
finish the wall rebuild the military uh
you know become energy independent again
so i'm looking for an american a first
agenda led by donald trump that we can
run on as a team and point out the flaws
of the biden agenda and we will clean
their clock in 1994 we won 73 seats to
take over the congress the house for the
first time in 40 years if we play our
cards right we will exceed that
you mentioned donald trump senator is he
the nominee in 2024 right now
yeah if he wants it uh unless there's
something coming out of left field i
don't see coming it's his nomination if
he wants it the republican base
appreciated him we don't appreciate all
the things he does sometimes but from a
policy point of view he was the most
successful president from a
conservative's point of view since
ronald reagan it is his nomination if he
wants it and he will be in the white
house in 2024 if he runs a disciplined
campaign and what he should do in my
humble opinion is remind people how he
secured the border how he took the fight
to isis destroyed the caliphate
how we were so much better off
internationally the iran deal is a
nightmare in the making for israel
regain energy independence so i think
2024 is president trump's election to
lose quite frankly 2022 is a blowout
year for the republicans in the house in
the senate if we'll talk about policy
real quick we've got about a minute left
you mentioned you know november 2022 we
both did it's a long ways off our
enemies are looking at us right now once
the beijing olympics are open if we
participate or not once they're done
the world could look much different what
what is the national security reality
we're facing right now
that the iran the iranians are not going
to go back to the table in good faith
they're going to try to break out and
dash toward a bomb and israel is going
to be in a box they're going to have to
use military force and the question for
me
are there any red lines for america we
should come up with red lines regarding
the iranian nuclear program and tell the
i tell if you cross them we're coming
after you not just israel i worry about
putin and ukraine china and taiwan and
all started with afghanistan pete thank
you for all you have done to remind
americans of our obligation to help
those left behind thank you for your
service happy new year but we're going
into a dangerous time the most dangerous
time i think since the 1930s
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else